der marß ist weit weg wirklich sehr sehr
weit weg astronauten müssen monatelang
im raumschuff überleben bis sie endlich
auf der Oberfläche des roten Planeten
landen und das ist nur der Anfang die
Besatzung muss sich auch gegen die
tödliche kosmische Strahlung schützen
und ohne Gravitation auskommen ohne dass
ihre Körper zu stark abbauen kein
Kinderspiel oder um diese
Herausforderungen zu meistern müssen
raumfahrtorganisationen wie die NASA und
Unternehmen wie SpaceX fortschrittliche
Technologien entwickeln dazu gehören
bessere Antriebssysteme um die Reisezeit
zu verkürzen und fortschrittliche
Lebenserhaltungssysteme um den
Astronauten auf der langen Reise ein
angenehmes Leben zu ermöglichen ein
weiteres Problem ist die Landung auf dem
marß die Atmosphäre des roten Planeten
ist dünner als die der Erde was bedeutet
dass herkömmliche Fallschirme und
landesysteme nicht ausreichen wir
brauchen also innovative Lösungen um die
Astronauten sicher auf der
Marsoberfläche abzusetzen und sie später
wieder zurück in den Orbit zu befördern
das ist technisch gesehen eine gewaltige
Herausforderung denn